[Music]
what is up guys and be showing you a
brand new video how to make money super
fast and it has no requirements so just
wear your best armor that you're willing
to lose because we will be in the
wilderness and bring a bunch of sharks
and whatever other food you want to eat
and then I'm going to assume the potion
and then bring how much GP you're
willing to spend or lose because you are
in the wilderness we're going to be
doing the death runes we're going to be
buying them from the abyss minigame Sam
rock mage and to do this you do need to
do the best mini quest but it's super
quick super easy
so just run up here to the north
you
so trade them again we're going to be
buying different and you drop shark
because I don't have enough room
trade them and there's always 500 that's
I know no one's been buying them and so
currently deserts are selling for 253
and in the shop they sell for 181 in the
beginning and only buy down to about 42
or 36 I ground 30 or 40 left in the shop
and then I switch worlds and then I do
it again super easy quick money I'll go
ahead and start the climber and see how
long it takes the only annoying thing
about this method is the stupid
skeletons intervening every three worlds
that jump but whatever just kill them
and then get back to buying your runes
alright I just finished and as you guys
know I spent 200 K so let's teleport to
edgeville and let's see how much I made
so it took exactly five minutes look at
that stopped it right then so 200 K put
it all in so 262k 149 is what I made in
five minutes 260 divided by five minutes
12 times 60 mm so 744 K so if the
decimals are selling for a lot you can
make anywhere from 742 800 K and
sometimes even 1 mil now let's go sell
them k so we put them in let's just kind
of instant sell them and see if they
sell alright they didn't so I'll show
you guys when they sell ok of course
right when I stop recording
they sell so I turn it back on but they
sold so for I sold them for 260 K now I
know I didn't do this for an hour but
this method is definitely an hourly
method because death will never not sell
alright thanks for watching guys stay
tuned for my next video